Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number
and that number is 2192. David P,
here's a great voicemail from the Eggman. You
know, I spoke about my time up north in the Hudson
Valley recently in New York. And I mentioned
you go north, you go west. It gets more and more
conservative. The man called in who lives way out
there, and he said, David, the Hudson Valley is
nothing. You should see what goes on where I live.
Speaker 2: Hey, Dave, I like how you describe
New York and how you said the further
north or west you get in New York state,
the further conservative yes it gets. I live in
western New York, Dave. I live a half hour from
Niagara Falls. Okay. That's how western
New York. I'm well, not that close, but.
We are so western New York. I call it West
Virginia. New York. Right. There's more Dale
Earnhardt oh three, NASCAR and Trump flags around
here than you would even see in Florida. Yeah,
absolutely insane. Really? There
are a ton of Confederate flags.
You would think that we're in the south. So the
caller from Texas yesterday who told you about
all the right wing anti-Trump? Let's go, Brandon
Flags. You describe West Virginia, New York.
When you talk about the Hudson Valley, I don't
think you have any idea how red it is up here.
I grow a large beard and drive an old pickup truck
just to be incognito, just so they won't kill me
for being a Jew. Oh, God. Shalom, brother.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So, I mean, obviously,
the area Eggman is describing is very different,
you know, Hudson Valley, lots of Jewish folks,
gay folks in Hudson Valley. And no need to
be hiding incognito the way that the egg
man describes hiding as a Jewish man in in
western New York. So, yes, I am aware that
Hudson Valley is not nearly as right wing as the
areas that Eggman is talking about. But yeah,
no. The further you get from New York City in
New York State, the wackier and wackier that
it gets. We have a fantastic bonus show for you
today. Chuck Schumer is going to be holding a
same sex marriage vote. Why? Why isn't this a
settled issue? Well, there's a PR reason why
it's being done and we're going to talk about it
on the bonus show. Secondly, we are going to dove
deep into the Jackson, Mississippi, water crisis.
And we're going to tie this into economic justice.
We're going to tie this into climate change. It is
a major story. It is another major water crisis.
Many people familiar with Flint, Michigan, this is
now another water crisis in Jackson, Mississippi.
And thirdly, there is a California school
district asking the families of the students
to rent out rooms to the teachers in the school
district. What why is that happening? It may or
may not surprise you. All of those stories
and more on today's bonus show. You can sign
up at join Packman dot.com and get instant
access to the bonus show. You can also,
if you're waiting for the exact perfect time to
get a membership for all of the stars to align,
for there to be a so-called double rainbow and
point to a membership on both ends of the rainbow.
Get on my newsletter at David Pakman dot com
because on 919 September 19th we are doing a
massive membership discount and you need only be
on my newsletter to be notified. All right. So I
would love to see you on the bonus show today,
but if you're waiting for the 919 special,
I also understand and either way, we'll
be back with a new show for you tomorrow.